Lên mạnh sả hội tìm đồng phạm, phán tấn đặt và miếc chi tội lập nhóm cấp tìm phạm giữa bà ngày.
Ngay vào mươi tháng 6, đặt cùng bốn người khác từ 2 mươi đến 8 mươi,
bị công an thành phố Ho Chi Minh tạm giữ khẩn cấp để điều tra hành vi gấp đài sản.
Trân bà dân và mẹ bà tội, bị sự lý vẻ hành vi không tốt giác tội phạm.
Theo điều tra, đặt là chủ miêu trong vụ cấp tìm bà, ở phương tân đông hiệp 8 hôm trước,
giòn hiểu nợ và cần tiền tiêu sài đã tên mạc tìm đồng phạm,
cùng cả nhóm khảo sát tị bàn trình bị dù sẽ mấy và lên kế hoại gấp.
Chiu 20 xa ổ tháng 6 sau khi khảo sát, nhóm của đặt tìa sẽ mấy đến tị bàn phân công người đập bữa tụp kính,
gấp 20 xa dự chuyển chỉ giá khoảng 20 bà bị trực đồng rồi tổ phát.
Cả nhóm đến phương viên hoa đồng này, các hiện chương hơn 5 kỳ lúc mẹ,
thay của náo, vì tàng phương tiệt và hung khí chia số bàn cấp được rồi bỏ chủn về nhiều địa phương.
Cảnh sát đã thu hồi 1 mỗi mỗi sợ dây chuyển hơn 1 chăm 20 bà chỗ đồng, cùng nhiều thang vận.
Đông thời mở giọc điều tra, chuyện tìm số tài sản còn lại.